over nine million people have taken part
in the erasmus+ programme over the last
30 years the Parliament is putting
forward a proposal to triple the funding
for the scheme in the post-2020 EU
budget this funding boost would create
even more mobility opportunities for a
wider range of people from school pupils
to adult learners the II he wants to
make the program more accessible to
people with disabilities or from
disadvantaged backgrounds but it's in
this model episodic nature future knows
you d da Giuliana drops Bonilla niggly
Deena Nicole such an economist apology
that was really supposed to be the
vision of Asian area to disaster dense
comorbid most erasmus+ is the emphasis
on lifelong learning whether that's
learning new languages developing
digital skills or practicing sport the
program will also introduce centres of
vocational excellence transnational
platforms that provide quality
vocational training so that people can
develop useful skills in certain sectors
from audible to the attack Center
recently chesty positively or not as Roy
puts is negligible on develops beneath
the toes of the three who Buddha to go
for meme them with the new funding
erasmus+ participants will be able to
gain skills that set them up for the
challenges of the 21st century in
sectors like digitalization and climate
you